you don't know a thing about me what
I've seen
we all need to run hope is not lost
today
you must face them
fight them
sure you're up for this
oh my gosh who's your favorite character
who's your favorite character hi
Harrison hi
hey youtubers its charlie happy thursday
there's new Star Wars footage so let's
bring it down we can see Finn with his
lightsaber we get to see more Han Solo
and Lee yet you get to see Han Solo in
real life surprising the [ __ ] out of
people there's been this new trend the
last couple of years where big Hollywood
movies try to do the reaction video
thing where they get like big stars to
surprise the crap out of normal people
Star Wars has just been using Harrison
Ford in their latest installment but the
big thing about this new clip is that
it's all about Finn we learned that he
is a flame trooper or at least he starts
out as one it looks like he completely
torches that village killing a whole
bunch of people Anakin Skywalker style
only instead of like Anakin going to the
dark side he has this complete crisis of
conscience so he just says smell you
later to the Empire and that's when he
bails him with Han Solo and then him
with the lightsaber looked like it come
much later in the film there were some
earlier clips where he had some dialogue
where he's like I have no idea what I'm
supposed to be doing like he's searching
for a purpose he just doesn't have an
identity yet so he gets swept up in this
big adventure and finds himself this
looks like it's on the Starkiller base
which is a lot of people are guessing is
probably inside this ice planet it would
be awesome if this trench opened up and
revealed the giant laser it would make
it a lot more defensible than the Death
Star any time I think about Death Star
logic I just go back to that Family Guy
clip it's just so hilarious can't we put
a piece of plywood over that hole or
something
but I just love how old and worn in all
the heroes stuff is looking Han Solo is
like the biggest character in most of
these clips and it looks like he hasn't
bought himself a new pair clothes in
like 30 years the blaster that he's
holding looks a little bit different
from the one he used in the original
trilogy but it does look reminiscent of
that that's one of the most fun things
about going to watch the original
trilogy is that everything looks like so
lived and worn in like yeah it's the
future they have amazing technology but
it looks so dirty like nobody has ever
cleaned it it gives you this really
grand visual sense of history that you
don't get from say like the Star Trek
films where it looks like the bridge of
the enterprise is an Apple Store but all
of you have also been asking about this
stormtrooper here this is what they're
calling the right control stormtrooper
and it looks like he has a stun baton
there I don't think that's a fibroblast
a burr strike is because it's charged
with energy but the ruins they're
fighting in looked like maz kanata's
temple it looks like the empire destroys
that
you might end up eating it during this
movie maybe she gets away her temple
looks like it gets destroyed did you use
the word hope quite a bit in there just
like so many visual things like costumes
as well as lines a dialogue that they
taken from the original trilogy and
given to different characters in this
new trilogy so because we are getting so
close to the movie coming out what I'd
recommend you do is you watch the
original trilogy I mean you can watch
the prequels too but at least watch the
original trilogy within like a week of
going to see Episode seven just so all
that is fresh in your mind so you'll
probably recognize a whole bunch of
familiar stuff during Episode seven they
kind of did that with the latest Bond
film with Spectre there's just like a
lot of the older Bond films inside that
film so exact same thing can happen with
Star Wars there's gonna be crazy Easter
eggs it's gonna be so much fun
that's really the reason you watch a
film like ten times like you watch it
the first time just for the fun of it
just because it's just a spectacle then
Yuri watch it for all the fun Easter
eggs what I think they're gonna end up
doing is it's just because we're so
close to the movie and they were calling
this a fin teaser they'll do this for
the other new characters so we might get
like a Rey teaser we might get a Poe
Dameron teaser we haven't seen a whole
lot of him yet Oscar Isaac was telling
funny stories about Harrison Ford on
this set he said he said because Poe
dameron's character is a big pilot
Harrison Ford is a big pilot in real
life he's like do you have any advice
for me you know for any like badass
piloting tips and Harrison Ford just
deadpan looked at him looks like nope
not no not really no no one will ever be
more casual than Harrison Ford is and a
lot of people are wondering what's gonna
happen to Han Solo in this new trilogy I
do think at some point he will end up
dying in the Millennium Falcon will be
his legacy like he'll pass it on to the
new characters just in terms of visual
imagery the Millennium Falcon is always
gonna be an identifier for Star Wars
like if you don't understand what the
story is for Star Wars
you know the Millennium Falcon like you
recognize it so old characters die off
new characters come in you know in 20
years
the price they'll be a Millenium Falcon
flying around the galaxy I don't even
want to think about how many Star Wars
films are gonna be in 20 years
there's at least three spin-offs that we
know about in three main films so that's
six in the next like eight to nine years
what's gonna happen next is I have a
whole bunch of footage for the flash
arrow crossover so I'm gonna do a video
for that and then I'm gonna do a video
for Jessica Jones I have a whole bunch
of Jessica Jones footage if you guys
didn't know Jessica Jones is dropping
every single episode is dropped
on Friday so be sure to book some time
for a marathon I'm gonna try to do at
least like four or five videos for the
episodes I don't know if I'll be able to
do a video for each episode but just be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
I'll be posting updates on Twitter and
Facebook throughout the weekend well I
guess wait for everything to post you
can click here for all the other Star
Wars trailers that I've been posting and
you can click here to catch up on
jessica jones before tomorrow night
thank you so much for watching everybody
looks at five I'll see you guys tonight